it was clonise birthday yesterday
[Music]
hey everyone long time no see so I'm
doing a question and answer video today
because I realize I haven't done one in
a really long time so I also enjoyed
what questions y'all have for me and I
got some really good ones there is a
giveaway on this video it is Dave shanks
latest book so if you would like to be a
part of that then stick around to the
end for details so I have pretty
selected some questions already I'm
going to go through them and then at the
very end there's gonna be a rapid-fire
round where I'm just gonna go through
and answer just some of the quick ones
so the first question comes from Barry
lemon or battery low three Mon what do
you think helps you the most to landing
your first tech job internships or
networking so I got my internships
through networking
so I guess networking is was the most
helpful thing I had a really bad GPA in
college and so I wasn't going to shine
in my academics so that I knew that I
had to establish relationships with
people who are already working at
companies so that I could get
internships at them luckily I was part
of the student org word there were other
computer science majors and there were
computer science new-year's who were
older than me so when they went to work
at full-time jobs then I would ping them
be like hey are you looking for interns
if so can I give you my resume and that
was really really helpful because at the
end of the day if I even think about
like as a full-time software engineer
now if I had an intern who would I hire
I would most likely reach out to the
people that I know already who are in
college who I trust and know and have a
relationship with so if you think about
it that way the networking is extremely
important and very very valuable okay so
the next question comes from Bruno he
asks how important is written
communication as a software engineer do
you think that's something that people
should give more importance as they grow
as engineers short answer oh heck yes
this is one of the skills that I didn't
work on in college and I really regret
that because I was like I'm a computer
science major why would I need to do
reading and writing that's stupid but
turns out it's a really really really
important part of the job so when it
comes to software engineering part of it
is about figuring out what the right
solution is and then coding it but
another huge part of it is to articulate
this solution to other people this is
incredibly important because if you
write a piece of code that maybe then
they like somebody finds a bug in then
you can't be the only person who knows
how to read and write that code that
creates what we call a bus factor aka if
something were to happen to you tomorrow
then that part of the code is completely
unknown and it's really hard to
understand so it's really really
important that you are able to
articulate your ideas and solutions
super well and that goes from everything
from how to name variables to writing
documentation to just like documenting
your thoughts so that you can maybe you
know propose a solution to people
whenever I'm going to start working on a
big project then I'm always going to
write out some documentation at first so
that I can talk about the solution with
other engineers to get their opinion to
see if this really is the right solution
I think this is actually like a whole
like thing like technical writing or
technical documentation I'm sure some
universities have some classes on that
next question so Jase asks what core
actions do or did you take to meet some
of your personal values that's a really
good question
I'm not sure that I actually like one on
a journey to find my personal values so
much is that like I figured out what my
personal values are through experiences
that I've had I I didn't like put myself
in situations stuff to figure out what
they are I think whenever conflict
arises and decisions need to be made
then those are the times that I feel
like I reflect on what's important to me
and like what my core values are if you
make something as big as should I work
at this company should I move here do I
want to live with these people or
something as small as divide by the
regular groceries or the organic gross
truth but I do think that putting
yourself out there and putting yourself
in situations where you're stretching
out of your comfort zone is a really
really great way to figure out what your
personal values are I also think that
sometimes you just need to let your
brain sit in a process and so sometimes
they'll just sit on the train and listen
to music and just stare out the window
just thinking about my life but yeah I
think that processing is super important
and so I don't know make sure you give
yourself time to do that especially when
we're in such a high-output society next
s Swiss coast asks how much time a
weekday spend on staying up-to-date with
new technologies umm I don't actually
reserve time to like stay up-to-date
with new technologies I stay up to date
with new technologies as needed the
thing that I really like about
technology and working in tech is not so
much the technology itself as it is the
fact that technology enables you and
other people to do things that you
couldn't do before so I'm not really
like the intense type to go and read
documentation for fun like do people
even do that but I do stamps a day like
relatively well going to meetups going
to talks and stuff gives me some more
information about what people are
talking about and so I make sure to like
stay plugged into those channels and
then also at work when we're working on
a new project and we have the chance to
really think about what the right
solution is and what tools we should use
then I'll go through and deep dive into
some new technologies to see if they're
like the right fit for what we're trying
to do but it is true that the tech world
is always reinventing itself and so
there's always new technologies and so I
think more so than like learning new
technologies and doing like that
homework it's more about being open
minded and flexible and not married to
anyone technology that's more important
Anthony asks in your personal or work
life how do you deal with stress /
feeling overwhelmed great question so
stress and feeling overwhelmed happens
when what work you have in front of you
feels too much like you can't hold on to
it and you
don't know if you can do all of it and
so the thing that honestly helps me the
most is to process sometimes like I'll
oftentimes just put a pause on it and
just be like okay hold on like before I
dive into doing all these things or
before the time comes let me just sit
with my feelings and my thoughts a
little bit and figure out like why am I
stressed and why am I feeling
overwhelmed I'm a highly introspective
person and so figuring out like hey is
there some sort of thing that I'm
worried about that underlies all of this
and what is it and why am I so afraid of
it in a way I kind of give myself like a
mini therapy session a few help and yeah
I'll figure out like hey can I actually
do all this are too all of these things
important for me to do can I drop some
of them can I lean on someone else for
help like those are all things that I do
to figure out like how can I sort my
feelings basically I will say it is a
very common thing for me to feel
stressed and overwhelmed and I'm still
trying to get better at processing them
and figuring out what the right solution
is like almost quicker because I think
when I get stressed and feel overwhelmed
I get very like I get very low and it
takes a long time for me to come back up
actually I think I'm in one of those
best right now but you know life is a
process everything's a process
everything will be okay everything will
be okay
okay next question Hayley I'm 22 about
to graduate college does there ever come
a point when you actually feel like an
adult in life yeah I'm not sure when I
first felt it though it might have been
like 21 when I started needing to pay my
own rent and get renters insurance and
get car insurance like when insurance
things comes up Oh health insurance too
that's when I feel a little bit more
like an adult but the times where I feel
like oh my god I'm like a full-blown
adult and I can't go back is when I have
like too many errands and things to do
on the weekend just to like live
select grocery shopping or just like
going to the post office or just like
being completely responsible for
yourself is when I feel most like an
adult and I'm 25 now and I still feel
like I don't want to be an adult and
sometimes the pressure of being an adult
in today's society is like overwhelming
but that's why it's important to take
one step at a time and meditate and
surround yourself with the people who
make you a better person who are really
important to you so it's okay you got
this although there are some really good
parts of adulting like yesterday I just
made a bag of popcorn just because I
could eat it okay so we're gonna go into
the rapid-fire round
Linda asks what camera do you use to
make videos most of the time I use my
canon g7x which I'm using right now and
I use an external zoom h1 mic I also
have a Rebel t5i by Canon but I use my
g7 X way more because it's a lot easier
to set up and use Manny Sandoval asks if
you hadn't been a programmer what other
career would you have chosen I would
have chosen to be a teacher my parents
are both teachers I'm really passionate
about educating and teaching and growing
people and that was super cool so that's
what I would have chosen and then he
asked also how did you start listening
to Natalia for COD a I started listening
to her because my brother recommended me
to her and he found out from another
friend of his I've also started
listening to monster parry day which is
super good and I'm going to the
Natalia's concert in November annoyance
psyched
John Choi asked crazy rich Asians
reactions was just great because they
just wash it two nights ago I think it
was great I think it was deep I think it
was kind of rom-com II which I'm not
super married to sort of yeah I don't
know I I just like cried like it was so
good I felt so lucky to have been able
to see it in theaters and like support
fellow Asian American and Asian actors
and I feel also fortunate to be a part
of this YouTube community too where I
get to do something sort of similar so
yeah I really liked it I recommend
everyone to go watch it
okay so Quinto so Jonah asked and
Japanese he'll play
down here Johannes Aleta Toki can say
vendor cigar curio Giovanni home Nando
Cora hey no coach in desuka
the scenario seemed a concession and a
yo tengo una decisión de casa a
conversation and a co de la silla
a medical man a pseudonym mosquito on ma
en Academy homogeneous Tony a doctor
como con Savin that Nassau inhomogeneous
out you can see nan desu kedo hiya the
sea wahoo don't know can save an
anonymous Julian do you do Iowa's
irrelevant with a interface builder or
100 percent programmatically at work I
do iOS development mostly just
programmatically I do use interface
builder sometimes when I'm building
prototypes or doing proof of concepts or
just whipping up something super fast
and last but not least Preston what were
the best computer science courses you
took in college that helped a lot with
your career so the ones that come to
mind are my software engineering class
and my engineering psychology class
software engineering we basically just
built an app over the course of a
quarter ten weeks with the team and we
had to track her progress we had to have
like requirements we had to build the
whole thing and that was the first like
hands-on experience I had building like
an actual app from end to end and I
learned about scrum and agile and like
velocity and blow the lock and so that
was really helpful in transitioning to
like a real software engineering job and
my engineering psychology class was more
around like human-computer interaction
and design but I think the thing that it
helped me to learn was like empathy and
trying to always put myself in the shoes
of the user so that we're building what
is most useful and usable that was a
class where you read the design of
everyday things by Don Norman and I
thought that book was really really cool
and I don't know
I'm kind of into like that sort of stuff
and so that was it that was really good
class so those are all the questions I'm
gonna answer today thank you so much to
everyone who submitted one clearly I
need to do more of these question and
answer videos because there were a lot
of questions so look out for that if you
like this video don't forget to give it
a thumbs up and subscribe to my channel
for more videos whenever that won't pee
and without further ado I wanted to talk
about the giveaway that I'm doing so
Dave Chang he's another youtuber I think
you've seen his videos all around the
internet they've probably been on the
recommended side of things on my videos
but he wrote a book called software
developer life where he collected a
bunch of stories and talked about a lot
of like things about working as a
software engineer there's a bunch of
topics in here and I think I've read
through a couple of these stories and
they're all really good I think it gives
you a really good idea like almost like
a guidebook for how to be a software
engineer and what to expect and he talks
about kind of his personal life and like
things that you know he thought about as
he was becoming a software engineer too
so I have about 10 softcover copies of
this book I also have ebook versions so
in order to qualify for the giveaway
then go to my Instagram at hello my you
go and comment on my latest post which
is going to be about this book tag a
friend and tell me why you're interested
in technology or software engineering or
coding so there's going to be about 15
to 20 winners and the giveaway is going
to close Saturday September 8th so be
sure to comment on my post by then and I
will message the winners via Instagram
DM this is my first time doing a
giveaway so I hope this is how this
works so good luck to everyone entering
I think this book is really great I
think it's a great field guide for
software engineers I'll also leave a
link in the description box below for
the Amazon links to buy this book great
that's it for today thank you so much
for tuning in as always and I'll see you
next time bye